i'm darren adatossiere an adobe insider
as well as a youtuber and presenter and
here today i am joined by the brilliant
the beautiful actress jasmine jobson who
a lot of you will probably already
recognize as the character jack from the
hit show top boy for which she was
nominated at bafta and she's just such
an inspirational role model for so many
people including myself uh so jasmine
it's so great to be speaking with you
today and thank you for joining us oh no
thank you for having me so as i
mentioned the theme for today's session
is all about how to break through in
your career which i feel like as a
creative we put in all of our passion
and hard work essentially preparing for
that opportunity and waiting for that
call and waiting for the big break um
but you know it's a journey which can
have so many different ups and downs and
i feel as though until you actually talk
to someone about their journey you have
no idea what's going on behind the
scenes so when you reflect on your
career jasmine what was that road like
to getting to where you are today and
how did your first acting gig come about
oh wow um well it's been a bit of a long
journey i mean i've been acting since
2013.
um
but my process into the industry was
pretty fast
um and slightly overwhelming
when you think about it um of how fast
it all happened um but i started acting
with a theater company called the big
house theater company it's a charity
based company based in east london and
they work with care leavers and
ex-prisoners and young people that have
flipped through the cracks of the social
system um to kind of like reform them
and we use acting as
the main thing to kind of like help them
express their feelings and their
emotions and things like that and i've
got the lead role on that production
and within about i think about three
weeks i was signed by my agency
um and then since then it's just been
onwards and upwards yeah it's literally
like all right so what's next gosh
that's so amazing um well i guess what
was next was top boy let's talk about
that how did that work come about in
particular wow um that was insane so um
i remember i got a phone call um from
dez hamilton
um saying that he wanted to see me for
top way so
i was super duper excited um got in the
space i think overall i had maybe four
auditions three recalls
in total and so i had my first audition
and i had three recalls after that
um and it was a bit of a long process
i'm not gonna lie you know sometimes you
know when you don't hear from jobs
you're like oh yeah no i haven't got it
it's all right better luck next time
um so i just kind of took it on the chin
really and then
i think it was like every month i was
getting a call back and i've thinking
wow what is going on they're really
taking their time here um
and then yeah i got a phone call one day
saying that i had bagged the job and i
was in the middle of washing my hair
proper old school got my head over the
bath with the shower go in for it and
i'm flinging shampoo and came literally
all over the bathroom as soon as i found
out that i bagged the job oh my god
that's so funny that's it she just
reminded me of when i got my phone call
saying that i'd got my formerly
presenting gig and literally being in
the middle of my bed halfway through and
up i swear these calls always come at
the most random times um and then having
to like act composed and as if i didn't
just wake up 10 seconds ago um but for
people that are watching this who you
know are still grafting they're still in
the process of you know hopefully
getting that phone call and going to
auditions what advice would you give to
them to make themselves stand out and
hopefully seize those opportunities
especially from an acting point of view
well first things first when it comes
down to casting directors and auditions
and things like that i would say
100 make sure that you're prepared
you know when you walk into that
audition space you need to know your
script you know and sometimes they say
oh we don't need you to be off book be
off book
be be the person that is different from
everybody else because now people have
seen that they don't need to be off book
some of them aren't really going to
bother you know be the person that
stands out be yourself have fun with it
you know if you show people that you're
being yourself and you're able to have
fun and you're flamboyant and all of
these different things you know and you
can take a script and turn it into your
own
you know that's what you need to be
doing have fun with it play about you
know and always leave a good lasting
impression because they will always call
you back one thing i pride myself in is
kind of not caring and this is something
that
maggie from the big house and her
company maggie norrish is
um but she was my mentor for a long long
time and i used to struggle with
kind of
how can i explain it i would say i'm
more worried about what other people
would think so when it comes down to
some parts in the script i'm like oh no
i'm not doing that it sounds silly you
know i'm always worried about how i'm
being perceived or something like that
and she just got me just you know let go
and not care about that and stop saying
things like i can't oh no my yeah i
can't do this i can't i can't i can't
there's no such thing as i can't
you can
you can try and if it doesn't work you
try a different way i feel like that
mindset in general in this industry is
so important because throughout your
career you can face so many different
obstacles but if you approach it with
that i can mindset then literally
anything is possible um it's something
which i always like to share over on my
youtube channel to my audience um as
it's something which i just believe is
so so powerful um and yeah it's amazing
that she was able to share that
knowledge with you and i guess nicely
leads me onto the topic of role models
actually um how important would you say
role models are with your career
and who are your role models in the
acting industry oh gosh i've got so many
that's what i'm saying i've got so many
inspirations from role models for me
it's definitely gotta be denzel
washington
he's absolutely amazing
um idris elba absolutely amazing big big
legend every role model has their own
little things
i mean it's like one piece from here one
piece from here one piece from here so
you know i would say it's a good thing
to have loads of role models or at least
like you know maybe five to ten that you
can look up to because then you can take
a little bit from everybody ah cause
that's what i like to do as well just
take as much in from everyone and then
like tailor it into your own path um but
jasmine you're obviously such a huge
role model for so many people out there
um so to everyone who's watching who
wants to be in your shoes and be an
actress or an actor um what advice do
you give and like practical steps that
they can do to make that a reality well
i would 110 recommend finding somewhere
that do acting workshops or something
like that
um i would also recommend possibly
getting involved in like writing
projects one of my friends right now was
actually doing a writing project which
is an intensive 12-week course i believe
um but she's absolutely amazing she's
also upcoming actress too
um so yeah i would say just just make
sure you're always keeping yourself busy
you know and in fact nowadays there's so
much going on you know you've got people
that are doing their youtube podcasts
and things like that you know so it's
like you could even possibly i don't
know create something with a group of
friends you know and film it and all
that kind of stuff create your own short
films play about improvise all that kind
of stuff you know so like
it's endless what you could do with your
free time and the fact that you've got
free time it means that you can actually
do more i think when it comes down to
like starting up i would say
never be intimidated or scared to
contact an agent or a casting director
you know
more time they'd be excited to hear from
you because they're always looking for a
fresh face you know and yeah just be
confident and just be yourself you know
enjoy yourself they'll love you no it's
so true honestly i wish i had someone
share that kind of advice with me at the
very beginning of my career because i
think you know being in an industry
where there's so many people that you
can compare yourself to um it can be
really easy for you to think oh maybe i
should act like this or maybe i should
do that um but the reality is there's
nothing better than just being yourself
and staying true to yourself and
remaining authentic so i really like
that piece of advice and honestly feel
like throughout this session you have
shared so many gems but i am just going
to ask you for one more um as i'm
conscious of time so if you want to
think of like one final wrap up from
everything we've discussed today um to
anyone who's starting out what advice
would you like to share with them i
personally didn't go to drum school or
anything like that i did go to an acting
group where it was like a 12-week
intensive workshop
um
but i didn't exactly go to drama school
or anything like that however
i would have loved to have gone drama
school
you know that i believe that in drama
school they teach you
a lot more than what i could have
possibly learned you know what i mean
but i've i've learned differently i feel
if i went drama school
i'd probably be interested in doing some
madness like the circus or something
like that because they have you doing
all these aerial tricks and work that is
wicked
i wish i wish i took the time out to go
drama school honestly so that's
something i would definitely recommend
because you do you learn a lot of skills
you take home a lot you know have fun be
yourself be confident and just go in
there with a set in your mind that
everything you touch will turn to gold
and you've got this
and i promise you when you stick with
that mantra you will always win you will
always win my mom's been telling me that
since i was a little girl and look where
i am now wow what a note to end on i
feel like i need that tattooed somewhere
don't know where
i'm gonna get it here
um honestly jasmine what an amazing note
to end on um i feel so inspired um it's
been so so great speaking with you um
and wish you all the best where are we
gonna see you next what are you up to
next cannot say i'm afraid the only
thing that i can say is keep your eyes
peeled for naughts and crosses too
jasmine it's been a pleasure thank you
so much and thanks to all of you guys
for watching i hope you enjoyed it and
from both of us we're wishing you all
the best of your creative careers thanks
everyone bye
yes god bless